und
jetzt kommen wir tatsächlich dann mit
den schon zu der debatte über die ich in
kräne werden eben jetzt ihr habt dann
aufgerufen sind die nächsten 100 minuten
ihre wahlzettel einzuwerfen für sie war
der mitglieder des ausschusses für
minuten beschlossen und als erste
rednerin erteile ich das wort der
bundesministerin annalena baerbock
annalena baerbock hat ja ihre erste
reise dann auch nach paris gemacht dann
war sie in der ukraine zunächst und dann
erst in moskau das ist sehr aufgefallen
und war ein positiver zug der deutschen
bundesregierung was gerade die ukraine
an geht es wurde da auch sehr
registriert in den letzten tagen war man
allerdings hier unzufrieden mit der
deutschen politik vor allem eine zeit
die für frieden und sicherheit auf
unserem kontinent entscheidend ist eine
zeit in der wir für unsere werte
eintreten müssen eine zeit in der
markige sprüche gut klingen aber
steilvorlagen für heftigste konsequenzen
sein könnte
das ist alles andere als eine einfache
politische zeit denn es ist schwer es
nicht als drohung zu verstehen wenn sich
über 100.000 soldaten mit panzern und
geschützen ohne nachvollziehbare gründe
in der nähe der ukraine fährt sammeln
und in belarus weitere truppen
zusammengezogen werden
und die russische regierung hat uns mit
forderung nach sogenannten
sicherheitsgarantien konfrontiert die
mit der europäischen sicherheits ordnung
nicht vereinbar sind die bundesregierung
reagiert darauf geschlossen und
entschlossen
und ehrlich gesagt nicht was uns gerade
so einfällt sondern natürlich in enger
abstimmung gemeinsam mit unseren eu
partnern unser nato partnern im rahmen
der g7 und da haben wir klipp und klar
deutlich
dass ein erneutes militärisches vorgehen
gegen die ukraine massive konsequenzen
für russland hätte auf dieser basis
arbeiten wir an einen starken und
sanktionspaket bei neuer aggression
stets die bandbreite unserer antworten
zur verfügung inklusive nur aus dem 2 ja
wir wollen jederzeit dialog aber es
braucht angesichts der aktuellen lage
auch härte die unmissverständlich
deutlich macht die souveräne gleichheit
von staaten und die grundpfeiler der
europäischen friedensordnung sind nicht
verhandelbar
diese heißen vertreten werk geschlossen
und zwar transatlantische und
europäische
in den vergangenen wochen ist kein
einziger tag vergangen an dem ich nicht
mit den amtskolleginnen und amtskollegen
aus der eu und aus der nato gesprochen
habe in zahlreichen telefonaten und
persönlichen treffen dabei hat sich
genauso wie der bundeskanzler zwei
botschaften unsere einigkeit ist unsere
stärkste waffe wenn man dieses wort
überhaupt gebrauchen möchte und ja das
kann man ganz offen sagen unsere rollen
sind dabei nicht komplett identisch wir
haben unterschiedliche rollen zwischen
unterschiedlichen ländern länder wie
polen und litauen übernehmen eine andere
rolle als länder wie italien frankreich
und eben auch deutschland und zwar aus
guten gründen denn unsere stärke in
diesem bündnis ist doch gerade dass wir
eine klare gemeinsame haltung haben und
zugleich unsere stärke in
unterschiedlichen rollen entsprechend
einsetzen
ganz anderes beispiel zu dem aus im
sport in einem team braucht es keine elf
mittelstürmerin die alle dasselbe machen
sondern elf spielerinnen die gut
miteinander können und die vor allem den
gleichen gemeinsamen spielplan im kopf
haben und unsere besondere rolle ist
dabei als deutschland als einziger
stärksten wirtschafts und
industrienationen der welt und führende
rolle in europa deutschland ist seit
jahren der größte geber in der ukraine
über den iwf über die eu und bilateral
aktuell arbeiten wir daran 150 millionen
euro aus einem ungebundene finanzkredite
möglichst schnell an die ukraine
auszuzahlen wir arbeiten natürlich bei
der impfstoffversorgung im energiesektor
und bei den reformprozessen im land
gemeinsam mit unseren partnern zusammen
und wir haben gemeinsam mit frankreich
und es war in den letzten jahren nicht
immer einfach dafür gesorgt dass wir als
europäerinnen und europäer und gerade in
diesem moment bei den sanktionen ganz
eng beieinander bleiben und deutschland
das braucht man gar nicht so
wegzuwischen deutschland unterstützt die
ukraine auch militärisch und zwar und
das möchte ich auch einmal deutlich
sagen an dieser stelle auf ukrainischen
wunsch liefern wir jetzt schutzhelme
auch das hat sich vor lambrecht nicht
einfach ausgedacht sondern das war der
besondere wunsch den wir hier jetzt nach
kommt das gleiche gilt für schutzbunker
bei odessa da gab es den anruf vor ein
paar tagen dass dir bitte unterstützen
wollen diese wieder instand zu setzen
und morgen weil wir direkt handeln wird
eine erste erkundungsreise dahin
stattfinden ukrainische offiziere haben
an der militärischen ausbildungshilfe
des
bundesverteidigungsministeriums steigen
um deutsche unterstützung für die
ukraine im rahmen des nato treuhand
fonds beträgt mehr als acht millionen
euro seit 2014 auch das wird gerade
vorbereitet in der eu
planen wir jetzt gemeinsam mit den
anderen europäischen partnern eine
ausbildungsunterstützung für die ukraine
im rat nato bündnis aber hier ist es
wichtig dass wir das unterscheiden
zwischen der unterstützung der ukraine
und im nato-bündnis ist deutschland seit
2014 eine der light nation in der vorne
präsenz im baltikum genauso stehen wir
auch heute zu unserer verantwortung im
bündnis dass wir in diesem jahr wieder
mit der beteiligung an der nato rp
leasing fonds in rumänien und in
bewegung aktiv sind meine damen und
herren auch darüber diskutieren wir
heute sehr offen weil das ist ja sinn
und zweck einer parlamentarischen
debatte nun fordern einige diesen kurs
zu verlassen und jetzt akut waffen zu
liefern
natürlich und das sage ich auch ganz
offen und ehrlich muss man in
schwierigen situationen sein handeln
immer wieder auch selbst kritisch
reflektieren aber ich sage ich ja auch
sehr klar und deutlich da ich ja nicht
nur chefdiplomatin unseres landes bin
sondern auch politikerinnen eine
pressemitteilung ist schnell geschrieben
aber seinen außenpolitischen kurs
einfach mal so um 180 grad zu drehen wo
gerade noch sage ich auch an die
unionsfraktion im sommer eine andere
entscheidung getroffen worden das sollte
man schon bei vollem bewusstsein tun und
vor allen dingen damit nicht türen für
deeskalation verschließen die sich
gerade in diesem moment so zaghaft
wieder öffnen
ich feiere ich war ja in der letzten
woche bewusst vor ort um darüber zu
sprechen sowohl in der ukraine als auch
in russland und präsident zielinski hat
gestern noch einmal deutlich gemacht wie
wichtig für ihn günstig dass er ein
baldiges gipfeltreffen dringend dringend
sich wünschen und dass es fortschritte
im verhandlungsprozess braucht und das
hat für mich das hat für diese
bundesregierung jetzt absolut oberste
priorität
gestern hat deswegen zum ersten mal seit
langem und auch das keine
selbstverständlichkeit wieder ein
physisches berater treffen im normandie
format stattgefunden wir haben über acht
stunden lang dort verhandelt ob da was
bei rauskommt wir wissen es nicht
niemand kann das in dieser zeit 100
prozentig sahen aber wer redet der
schießt nicht daher ist es fatal die
wiederaufnahme von dialog jetzt einfach
so ab zu tun und warum weil seit zwei
jahren die menschen im don was in dieser
pandemie noch mal ganz besonders leiden
und das minsker abkommen das dreht sich
ja gerade darum den menschen in der
region die zum teil als ich da war hat
eine botschaftsmitarbeiterin gesagt ich
bin immer mal wieder hingefahren und
meine kranke oma zu sehen aber seitdem
ich jetzt ein kleines baby habe mache
ich das nicht mehr was ist wenn ich
nicht mehr zurückkommen das sind die
lebensschicksale um die es hier geht das
ist die
alltagssituation für viele viele
tausende von menschen und deswegen ist
das minsker abkommen so entscheidend
wir werden
zum schluss vor präsidenten wir werden
klagen ja mein französischer amtskollege
ri jong un isch übernächste woche wieder
in die ukraine auch an die kontakt linie
reisen und gerade auch die intensiven
bemühungen der osze an dieser stelle zu
unterstützen und ich sage sehr sehr
deutlich das was wir gerade tun
wirtschaftlich in der zusammenarbeit das
ist essentiell in dieser situation wir
müssen in diesem moment die ukraine
gerade wirtschaftlich und finanziell
stärken denn im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert da bedroht man nicht nur mit
kanonen sondern wir haben noch in der
pandemie gesehen was passiert wenn
lieferketten ausfallen und deswegen
haben wir habe ich ganz bewusst
entschieden dass wir nicht unser
botschaftspersonal reduzieren sondern
dass wir die ukraine dadurch
unterstützen dass wir präsent sind dass
wir investieren dass diplomatie
absoluten vorrang hat und dass wir
gemeinsam für die sicherheit der ukraine
und in ganz europa eintreten herzlichen
dank
die chefdiplomatin deutschlands annalena
baerbock die deutsche außenminister hat
hier noch einmal die deutsche
außenpolitik
verteidigt
vorrang der diplomatie den würde
sicherlich keiner widersprechen das
auftreten an der ein oder anderen stelle
der deutschen bundesregierung aber das
wirkt für viel kritik im ausland auch
die helm lieferung gestern 5000 helme
das hat der für spott gesorgt und jetzt
erhält hier friedrich merz das wort ist
ja gewählt worden als neuer cdu chef
wird aber dieses amt offiziell erst ab
dem 31 januar begleiten
damen und herren wir stehen vermutlich
alle noch unter dem eindruck der reden
die wir heute morgen
zum jahrestag der befreiung des
konzentrationslagers auschwitz
gehört haben
und es erfüllt mich mit etwas beklemmung
wenige minuten später
wie im deutschen bundestag reden zu
müssen über die frage ob da nicht
möglicherweise erneut ein krieg droht in
europa ein krieg war werbung kein
fußballspiel
und der bundeskanzler wir hätten uns
durchaus vorstellen können dass nicht
die bundestagsfraktionen auf unsere
initiative hin heute morgen hier diese
debatte waren tragen sondern dass sie
als bundeskanzler der bundesrepublik
deutschland zu dieser lage eine
regierungserklärung abgeben und
anschließend eine debatte im deutschen
bundestag stattfinden
es droht ein krieg in einem teil unseres
kontinents der von den verbrechen des
zweiten weltkrieges in besonders
brutaler weise
betroffen waren auf dem territorium der
heutigen ukraine hat das grausame
verbrechen an der zivilbevölkerung
gegeben vor allem an der jüdischen
bevölkerung
die ukraine hat allein im zweiten
weltkrieg mehr als ein viertel ihrer
bevölkerung verloren
und schon vor dem zweiten weltkrieg war
die ukraine vielfältig auf war
der russischen bürgerkrieg der
kollektivierung unter stalin und nicht
zuletzt des hitler stalin paktes von
deswegen vblock erlaube ich mir schon in
hinweis wenn sie an anderer stelle mit
verweis auf die deutsche geschichte
zur rücksichtnahme und
zurückhaltung ermahnt die wir teilen
dann geht das nicht nur an die adresse
russlands dann geht das auch und ganz
besonders an die adresse der ukraine ich
denke wir müssen deshalb heute zunächst
einmal
einige dinge miteinander klären wir sind
uns vermutlich hier im deutschen
bundestag weitgehend einig dass russland
ein europäisches land ist dass wir alle
gern als teil einer dauerhaften
politischen ordnung in europa sehen
würden und ich will persönlich
hinzufügen die meisten von uns haben in
erinnerung die rede die wladimir putin
von dieser stelle aus wenige tage nach
nine eleven im jahr 2001 fast
ausschließlich in deutscher sprache vor
dem deutschen bundestag gehalten hat ich
habe diese rede hier im parlament
miterlebt und ich sage ganz ausdrücklich
ich bedauere dass die damalige
bundesregierung gerhard schultern die
angebote die putin gemacht hat nicht
angenommen hat und ich bedaure dass ich
als oppositionsführer im jahr 2001 die
bundesregierung gerhard schröder die
vier wochen später nicht gefragt habe
warum
geburt nicht angenommen hat aber meine
damen und herren das war der putin von
diejenigen von ihnen die an der
sicherheitskonferenz im jahr 2007 in
münchen teilgenommen haben wissen dass
wir seit dem jahr 2007 einen anderen
putin haben und dieser putin und dieses
russland die stabilisiert systematisch
seit 15 jahren die politische ordnung in
europa und dies unter beständiger
verletzung der verträge und
vereinbarungen die russland und zuvor
die sowjetunion verbindlich eingegangen
sind cyber-angriffe auf den deutschen
bundestag
auftragsmorde und giftanschläge im
eigenen land und in anderen ländern
europas bis hin zu der als tiergarten
mord in die öffentlichkeit gelangten
ermordung eines georgios hier in
unmittelbarer nähe wenige hundert meter
vom deutschen bundestag entfernt im
tiergarten das sind der tägliche bestand
des handelns des russischen staates
vorrangiges ziel der permanenten die
stabilisierung durch russland ist ganz
offensichtlich seit einigen jahren die
ukraine erst die völkerrechtswidrige
annexion der krim zugleich das
eindringen russischer truppen und
paramilitärischer einheiten in die ost
ukraine und seit einigen wochen nun ein
massiver truppenaufmarsch an mehreren
stellen auch in belarus im zangen
angriff auf die gesamte ukraine meine
damen und herren ich hoffe dass wir uns
hier im deutschen bundestag in der
feststellung einig sind dass diese
gefährdung des friedens in europa
ausschließlich von der russischen
föderation und ausschließlich von
wladimir putin ausgeben
gesagt
herr bundeskanzler
sagen wir ihnen trotz der sehr unklaren
position zu russland die offensichtlich
in ihrer eigenen partei auf ihr handeln
bestimmt nicht allein wir die opposition
im deutschen bundestag die menschen in
unserem land erwarten von ihnen jetzt
dass sie im deutschen parlament eine
klare einschätzung der lage aus ihrer
sicht geben und dass sie vor allem die
konsequenzen daraus für deutschland und
für europa aufzeigen wir erwarten von
ihnen dass sie so wie alle ihre
vorgänger im amt des bundeskanzlers der
bundesrepublik deutschland initiativen
ergreifen mit partnern in der
europäischen union und wenn es nicht
alle 27 sein können und sein wollen dann
wenigstens mit frankreich mit polen mit
den baltischen staaten auch mit
großbritannien hier gemeinsame klare
antworten zu geben dies erfordert eine
klare und
unzweifelhafte haltung der regierung der
bundesrepublik deutschland meine damen
es kann
es kann sein dass wir noch etwas zeit
haben aber dann herr bundeskanzler darf
an der europäischen und dann darf auch
an der deutschen entschlossenheit kein
zweifel entstehen und diese zweifel sind
da sie haben es immerhin fertig gebracht
in dem ansonsten heillos zerstrittenen
amerikanischen kongress eine vollkommen
einheitliche einschätzung des unklaren
bildes und der unzuverlässigkeit der
bundesrepublik deutschland entstehen zu
lassen und das ist ihre verantwortung
der bundeskanzler das ist ihre politik
sie führen nicht weder in deutschland
noch in europa und wer wie sie
und wer wie sie diese zweifel entstehen
lässt sich erkennbar jedenfalls für die
deutsche öffentlichkeit es kann ja sein
dass sie im stillen viel gutes tun aber
wer erkennbar sich um dieses problem zu
wenig kümmert der vergrößert das risiko
nicht nur für die bevölkerung in der
ukraine sondern auch für die politische
stabilität in ganz europa
hat dir oder falls vorgehalten dass er
zum einen wir keine regierungserklärung
zu diesem wichtigen thema abgehalten hat
sondern die fraktionen diese debatte
beantragen musste dass er keine klare
haltung zurück keine krise erkennen
lässt und keine klare führung aus
bemerkenswert dass friedrich merz hier
der erste redner sein durfte und der
fraktionschef ihnen dieses rederecht
eingeräumt hat die union muss ja noch
klären und wie das zwischen den beiden
männern in zukunft laufen sollte aber
immerhin auch die spd stellt ihren
parteichef auf nämlich lars klingbeil
hier als nächsten redner
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
die bundesregierung ist gestartet in
einer schwierigen internationalen
situation
wir hatten noch nicht einmal die tinte
trocken unter dem koalitionsvertrag als
die neue regierung schon gefordert war
mit nicht nur einer schwierigen
politischen lage und der pandemie
sondern auch mit einer schwierigen
außenpolitischen lage und dem sich
zuspitzenden konflikt an der
russisch-ukrainischen grenze umzugehen
und ich will meine rede damit beginnen
dass ich den bundeskanzler und der
bundes außenministerin dankte für das
engagement und die intensität des
engagement die beide stellvertretend für
die ganze bundesregierung in den letzten
wochen an den tag gelegt haben es ist
wichtig dass deutschland internationale
europäische verantwortung übernimmt das
erleben wir von dieser bundesregierung
dafür ein großer dank an dieser stelle
und
herr merz
glückwunsch an dieser stelle nochmal zu
wahren ich sage ihnen auch ich habe mich
gefragt wie lange diese ruhige
bedächtige tonlage die wir in den
letzten wochen von ihnen erlebt haben
wie lange sie anhält und sie haben recht
außenpolitik ist kein fußballspiel sagt
auch außenpolitik ist mehr als schwarz
weiß außenpolitik hat nicht diese simple
einteilung in gut und böse
ich habe aber auch eine blitz und
außenpolitik dient auch nicht der
selbstfindung einer neuen
oppositionsgruppe
ich glaube
ich glaube dass
die bundesrepublik deutschland immer
geprägt war davon dass wir einen konsens
hatten in der außen- sicherheits-
politik der größer war als eine
regierungs merkt und ich wünsche mir und
diesen wunsch möchte ich äußern dass wir
das beibehalten
ich habe mich gefragt auch gerade in
ihrer rede und auch in den letzten tagen
wenn man einige kommentare hört was
wünscht man sich eigentlich an der
spitze des landes wir hatten eine
bundeskanzlerin die 16 jahre und ich
will das hier erwähnen das land gut
geführt hat indem sie lösungen gefunden
hat aber nicht auf überschriften gesetzt
und das ist auch das was ich jetzt von
einer bundesregierung es gibt andere
beispiele ein konservativer staatslenker
in großbritannien der die europäische
union mit kaputt macht ein konservativer
und freund ja gerade der csu in ungarn
mit herrn orban der die europäische
union kaputt macht ein ich erinnere mich
daran wie die junge union damals die
wahl fand in jump als konservativen
staatslenker gefeiert hat der auf
überschriften gesetz hat aber
internationale beziehung kaputt gemacht
hat herr merz das worum es geht ist doch
dass wir hier eine bundesregierung haben
die mit bedacht und lösungsorientiert
eine schwierige lage wie wir sie an der
russisch-ukrainischen grenze haben die
dort lösung sucht und das ist das was
ich von einer bundesregierung erwartet
und deswegen noch mal ein großer dank an
olaf scholz an annalena baerbock für das
was wir in den letzten wochen erlebt und
worauf kommt es jetzt an
ich will ein partner tepee klar dass
erst ist und das müssen wir uns jeden
tag bewusst machen mitten in europa
droht grad ein krieg zwei flugstunden
von berlin weg droht eine kriegerische
auseinandersetzung die diesen kontinent
nachhaltig verändern können und deswegen
geht es nicht um eine innenpolitische
debatte es geht darum außenpolitisch
alles jetzt zu tun damit eine
militärische eskalation der lage
abgewandt werden kann zweiter punkt um
den es geht und da bin ich völlig klar
und das sage ich in aller deutlichkeit
wir benennen sehr deutlich von wem die
eskalation aus geht es ist die russische
seite die eskalation die wir erleben
geht gerade von russland aus und wir
blicken mit großer sorge auf die
völkerrechtswidrige aktionen der krim
auf innenpolitische entwicklung in
russland die verletzung des
völkerrechtes wir sind da klar wenn die
territoriale integrität der ukraine
angegriffen wird dann gibt es eine klare
eine konsequente und eine entschiedene
antwort die diese bundesregierung mit
den internationalen partnern abgestimmt
hat und
herr merz ich weiß gar nicht was
unverständlich ist an der aussage des
bundeskanzlers alle optionen liegen auf
dem tisch ich meine es war nicht der
vorsitzende der fdp oder die
vorsitzenden der grünen oder der spd die
als erstes gerufen haben die aber es
wirft nehmen wir aus das waren sie haben
der russischen seite gezeigt dass wir
wort wackeln an dieser stelle und der
satz alle optionen auf dem tisch wer
muss von allen hier unterschrieben
werden und das ist mein dritter punkt
wir brauchen klarheit und wir brauchen
konsequenz wenn die russische seite die
grenze politisch geografischen
überschreitet aber bis dahin bis dahin
konzentrieren wir uns doch jetzt bitte
darauf über frieden zu reden wir
brauchen doch nicht jeden tag drogen wir
brauchen nicht jeden tag drohgebärden
wir brauchen nicht jeden tag eine
weitere eskalation der situation sondern
wir machen deutlich als bundesrepublik
deutschland das ist gerade darum geht
frieden zu organisieren jedes gespräch
zu nutzen jeden dialog jeden tisch an
denen man sich setzen kann ist wichtig
damit frieden organisiert wird und ich
sage hier ausdrücklich waffen zu liefern
bedeutet nicht friedensbemühungen zu
stärken und deswegen ganz klar wir
liefern keine waffen in die ukraine
und der letzte punkt der letzte punkt
der nicht ansprechen will ja wenn die
aktuelle situation überwunden ist müssen
wir auch wieder die größere perspektive
spannt eine dauerhafte friedensordnung
in europa wird es nicht geben gegen
russland sondern nur mit russland und
deswegen muss der russischen seite klar
signalisiert werden ihr habt euch der
verband ihr seid auf einem völlig
falschen weg das was er gerade tut rückt
diese europäische friedensordnung in
weiter ferne aber das angebot sich an
den tisch zu setzen und darüber zu reden
wie wir frieden und stabilität in europa
organisieren dieses angebot bleibt
bestehen herzlichen dank
belasten weil der spd-parteivorsitzende
lobte hier die klare führung der
bundesregierung namentlich des kanzlers
und der außenministerin und hat auch
noch einmal unterstrichen dass
deutschland der mittler sein könnte
jetzt gibt es eine kurzintervention
gleich für völlig merzig der botschaft
der ukraine seine exzellenz herr
doktorand remake herzlich willkommen
der un-botschafter laut dieser debatte
und friedrich merz jetzt mit einer
kurzintervention
herr kollege klingbeil wir nehmen das
angebot einer weitest möglichen
zusammenarbeit in der außenpolitik in
der sicherheitspolitik in der
verteidigungspolitik mit ihrer
bundesregierung ihrer fraktion den
koalitionsfraktionen an und damit genau
an dieser stelle keine irritationen
entstehen ich habe es hilft in der tat
angesprochen ich habe um im bild zu
bleiben was ich gewählt habe auf die
sprengkraft hingewiesen die eine
aussetzung von swift bedeuten würde aber
es liegt auch für mich ausdrücklich mit
auf dem tisch der möglichkeiten wenn es
darum geht diese bedrohung abzuwenden
nicht nur für die ukraine sondern für
ganz europa es ist nicht vom tisch es
bleibt auf dem tisch es hat allerdings
erhebliche rückwirkungen auch auf unsere
volkswirtschaft und die müssen wir alle
bedenken wenn wir auch über solche
instrumente sprechen
[Applaus]
und ich erteile das wort dem nächsten
redner stefan kreuzer fw fraktion
frau präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren lassen sie uns zusammen
eine zeitreise in das jahr 1962 machen
der damalige amerikanische präsident
kennedy drohte der sowjetunion mit einem
dritten weltkrieg sollten sie atomare
waffen auf kuba quasi vor der haustüre
der usa stationieren und wenn sie mich
fragen tat er das zu recht warum tat er
das es waren die sicherheitsinteressen
der vereinigten staaten massiv bedroht
lassen sie uns einmal 30 jahre
weitergehen circa 30 jahre ins jahr 1999
polen tschechien und ungarn treten der
nato bei etwa fünf jahre später 2004
folgten bulgarien estland lettland
litauen rumänien die slowakei und
slowenien
betrachten wir einmal das verhältnis
zwischen der russischen föderation und
der ukraine es ist in der
postsowjetischen zeit geprägt durch
scharmützel um gas und die krim lassen
sie uns über die krim sprechen 180 jahre
war sie russisch nachdem sich von den
osmanen erobert wurde modifiziert und
1954 hat gross stoff aus einem
verwaltungsakt es ging damals um den bau
einer eisenbahnlinie
die creme der ukraine angegliedert die
krim hat seitdem zweimal versucht zu
russland zurückzukehren
1994 und zuletzt 2014 in einem
referendum wo über 7 über 96 fast 97
prozent der bevölkerung der krim für den
anschluss an russland stimmte
völkerrechtlich gibt es da verschiedene
bewertungsmöglichkeiten aber damit
unsere außenministerin und sehr
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen mehr zu
sagen können was mich beängstigt ist
diese stimmungsmache gegen russland und
zwar in den medien in der politik und
vor allen dingen auch hier in diesem
hohen hause dem bundestag wir müssen nur
unseren vorrednern zugehört haben dann
sehen wir dass es sich um eine
unsägliche rhetorik androht szenarien
von krieg und einstellung von
gaslieferungen in dieses horn stößt auch
der
der botschafter melnik der ukraine der
heute in diesem hause zu gast ist das
freut mich nicht so können es ihnen auch
sagen die forderung nach waffen können
wir deutschen nicht erfüllen und ihre
unsägliche kriegstreiber wright kann ich
nur verurteilen sie beleidigen
deutschland sie ziehen sie ziehen
unwürdige vergleiche der deutschen
geschichte zum
nationalsozialismus frau berbalk
untergehen vorgehen hat wäre so ein
botschafter ins auswärtige amt
einbestellt worden und ein
staatssekretär hätte ein sehr
nachhaltiges gespräch mit ihm geführt
es gibt aber auch andere töne
viel zeit mehr als schön war äußerte
verkürze das russland respekt auf
augenhöhe möchte und auch verdienen
würde dass krieg absoluter nonsens sei
und dass die creme weg ist und auch nie
wieder zurückkommen wird ich sage sind
meine damen und herren dieser offizier
hat nicht nur recht er hat auch schneit
wem nutzt diese eskalation an der grenze
in der ukraine bono die usa nutzen die
pipeline nord stream zwei als
druckmittel deutschland soll eigene
interessen für fremde interessen opfern
wir schauen uns die eu sanktion von 2014
an die übrigens ganz geschickt die usa
ausklammern leidtragende sind vor allem
die russland mit einem wirtschafts
verlust von 36 milliarden us-dollar und
direkt gefolgt von deutschland mit
weitem abstand zu allen anderen
europäischen staaten zusammen 23
milliarden us-dollar wir schneiden uns
mit diesen sanktionen ins eigene fleisch
das muss ein ende haben die
us-wirtschaft übrigens hat im gleichen
zeitraum ein plus in diesen geschäften
gemacht damit muss schluss sein die
ukraine braucht eine lösung eine lösung
die sowohl auf der einen seite die
interessen der ukraine
berücksichtigt auf der anderen seite
aber auch die sicherheitsinteressen der
russischen föderation wir haben es eben
gehört und da gebe ich ihnen recht einen
frieden ohne russland wird es nicht
geben lassen sie mich ein fazit ziehen
es gibt keinen krieg ist droht auch kein
krieg das droht kein gas mangel die
sicherheitsinteressen russlands müssen
wir ernst nehmen dann klappt das auch
mit dem weltfrieden fielen meine damen
und herren
stefan kreuzer von der afg
ich noch mal an die parlamentarische
wortwahl erinnern und dass dieser auch
hier im hohen hause eingehalten wird
vielen dank
der nächste redner ist alexander kraft
lambsdorff fdp fraktionen
aufnahmen service der
fraktionsvorsitzende für den bereich
außenpolitik der präsidentin meine damen
und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wir führen hier eine debatte
unter dem titel frieden in europa
sichern weil wir eine kriegsgefahr in
europa sehen die nach übereinstimmender
analyse in diesem haus mit ausnahmen die
nicht weiter erheblich sind von russland
aus geht und ich möchte an diesem tag am
januar daran erinnern dass man den
menschen in russland
nichts über die gräuel des krieges
erzählen muss der 27 januar 1944 war der
tag an dem die rote armee die blockade
von leningrad nach über 900 tagen
belagerung durch die deutsche wehrmacht
endlich durchbrochen hat über eine
million menschen sind dabei ums leben
gekommen die blockade von leningrad war
ein kriegsverbrechen ein grauenhaftes
kriegsverbrechen sie steht symbolisch
für all die opfer die die völker der
sowjetunion erbracht haben im zweiten
weltkrieg aber alle völker eben auch
weißrussen ukrainer genauso wie die
russen meine damen und herren wir
verneigen uns vor diesen opfern und wir
nehmen die verantwortung an die uns aus
diesen taten erwächst
aber so wenig man den menschen in
russland über die gräuel des krieges
sagen musst du dringend scheint es sein
im dialog mit der aktuellen russischen
regierung wir müssen diesen krieg
abwenden der uns in europa droht und
dazu und das will ich hier ausdrücklich
unterstreichen ist diplomatie auf allen
kanälen das mittel der wahl im
nato-russland-rat im normandie format
bilateral in der osze und mit der
europäischen union das ist der weg wie
wir versuchen frieden zu schaffen in
europa meine damen und herren
nun hat gestern außenminister lawrow
verkündet dass für die osze und der
europäische union kein platz am
verhandlungstisch sei für mich heißt das
dreierlei erstens mit ihrer ablehnung
der osze zeigt die russische föderation
das offenbar ihr präsident nicht weniger
will als die europäische friedensordnung
von 1990 zurück zu drehen die ablehnung
der karte von paris die ablehnung des
wiener dokuments vielleicht sogar die
ablehnung der schlussakte von helsinki
wir müssen die russische seite daran
erinnern dass sie all diese dokumente
unterschrieben hat und dass sie sich an
sie zu halten hat
zweitens
als europäische union bleibt der frieden
auf dem europäischen kontinent unser
erstes und fundamentales interesse
wir sind bereit russische
sicherheitsbedürfnisse zu adressieren
auf der basis des völkerrechts aber wir
sind nicht bereit meine damen und herren
wie es victor ja da fährst dann
formulierte musste der russischen
regierung die schaffung einer zweiten
wirklichkeit zuzugestehen nicht die nato
bedroht russland auch nicht die ukraine
nicht die nato hat die europäische
friedensordnung durch die verlegung von
100.000 soldaten an die grenzen eines
anderen landes gestört nicht die nato
hat soldatinnen und soldaten stehen in
ländern gegen den willen der betroffenen
regierungen keine nato soldaten stehen
in georgien in der republik moldau oder
in der ukraine es sind die soldaten der
russischen föderation meine damen und
herren die russische seite wäre
erheblich glaubwürdiger wenn präsident
putin den rückzug dieser truppen
anordnen würde
glücken wir dürfen uns als westen nicht
auseinanderdividieren lassen ein
einmarsch russlands in die ukraine die
vernetzung verletzung der territorialen
integrität und ihre grenzen muss weitere
ernsthafte konsequenzen für moskau haben
politisch wirtschaftlich und finanzieren
und ich finde es in diesem hinsicht in
dieser hinsicht extrem
gut wie eng die abstimmung mit unseren
europäischen aber auch mit unseren
amerikanischen partnern in der nato
verfolgt die nato hat gerade erklärt
dass sie bereit ist weiter mit russland
zu reden die amerikanische seite hat
erklärt dass sie achteinhalb 1000
soldaten in erhöhte alarmbereitschaft
versetzt die bedeutung von worten und
gesten ist allen klar aber auch das
ziehen von roten linien ist nötig aber
es ist dann wichtig diese roten linien
dann auch zu respektieren und das heißt
alle optionen liegen auf dem tisch meine
damen und herren wir sollten keine von
dem tisch nehmen um die kalkulation
derer die in moskau die kriegsgefahr
anreizen leichter zu machen im gegenteil
machen wir die kalkulation so schwierig
wie möglich machen wir den krieg in
europa unwahrscheinlich sichern wir den
frieden auf unserem kontinent herzlichen
dank
ja viel angst hat
in korea die momentane aggression
zumindest kommt mittlerweile fast 120
tausend mann zusammen gezogen von den
russen an den grenzen zur ukraine und
sogar in weißrussland
und gregor gysi der außenpolitische
sprecher der linksfraktion wird das wird
sicherlich auch noch mal aus seiner
sicht bewerten
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
die schwierigkeit bei dem gegenstand der
gespräche mit russland besteht daran
dass das so unterschiedlich gesehen wird
der west möchte gerne über die gefahren
der ukraine sprechen russland will über
eine neue sicherheits ordnung in europa
sprechen und mit einer neuen sicherheits
ordnung wären vielleicht auch die
gefahren für die ukraine zu minimieren
die aber auch selbst versuch unterlassen
muss den konflikt ausschließlich
militärisch zu sehen
welche voraussetzungen gibt es gerade
gegen den willen russlands müssen wir
die osze ein stärkerer stärken ihr ein
starkes gewicht wieder geben dass sie
früher mal hatte heute kaum noch die
nato kann nicht quasi als einzige säule
europäischer sicherheit verstanden
werden und darf sich nicht wie bisher
gegen russland sehen frieden und
sicherheit in europa das wurde hier
schon gesagt gibt es nicht ohne
geschweige denn gegen russland
außenminister der frühere außenminister
genscher hat am zweiten februar 1990 im
beisein vom damaligen us-außenminister
bk folgendes wörtlich gesagt wir waren
uns einig dass nicht die absicht besteht
dass nato-verteidigungsminister
denen nach osten das gilt nicht nur für
die ddr sondern ganz generell spielt
dann hat das auch
kohl gesagt im gegensatz dazu sind 14
staaten in die nato aufgenommen worden
den usa den usa wird immer ein
sicherheitsabstand zugebilligt wenn
jetzt wirklich schwer bewaffnete
russische soldaten auf kuba und
venezuela stationiert werden würden das
würden die usa nicht zulassen und ich
stelle an sie die frage warum belegen
sie der atommacht usa ein
sicherheitsabstand und der atommacht
russland nicht das verstehe ich
ihre kritik am truppenaufmarsch in
russland besteht zu recht aber diese
kritik ist nicht aufrichtig wenn man das
agieren der nato durch die nähe ihrer
truppen zur russischen grenze die dort
stattfindende nato manöver und dem
beschuss der ost ukraine durch
kampfdrohnen der ukrainischen armee aus
lässt übrigens drohnen mit deutscher
technologie aus der türkei apropos
türkei sie hat nicht nur truppen und
kriegsgerät auf eigenem territorium an
irgendeiner grenze stationiert sondern
ist völkerrechtswidrig einmarschiert in
syrien hat luftangriffe geflogen alles
nur gegen kurdinnen und kurden und das
auch noch ohne die nato zu informieren
was sagt die bundesregierung dazu passt
nicht jeden tag würden über russland
gesprochen aber kaum über die türkei
offensichtlich darf ein nato-partner
alles das untergräbt die glaubwürdigkeit
der politik
aber ich sage auch etwas die nato sagt
das sagen sie ja auch kraft sondern sie
hat nicht die geringsten aggressiven
absichten das mag ja sein aber wenn es
die russische führung nicht glaubt nutzt
uns das nicht es gibt nur ein weg das
sind verhandlungen
niederungen können auf gar keinen fall
die antwort sein in den neunziger jahren
war von einem gemeinsamen haus europa
die rede das wird man nicht auf
gegenseitiger hochrüstung bauen können
die fdp sollte vielleicht noch mal bei
hans dietrich genscher
seit gestern
gibt es mit aufforderung des westens ich
wäre dafür dass die nato aufforderung an
russland stellt zum beispiel ende aller
hacking angriffe eine reduzierung von
truppen manövern in bestimmten gebieten
keine gefährdung es souveränität der
ukraine oder anderer länder wenn man das
macht sie haben ihre forderung wir
hätten unsere forderung dann kann man
verhandlungen führen und so lange man
verhandlungen führt gibt es auch keinen
krieg das ist das wichtig sind
außerdem bei den verhandlungen muss man
auch moskau entgegenkommen sonst machen
verhandlungen gar keinen sinn man bisher
nicht alles übernehmen aber man muss
entgegenkommen und die bereitschaft dazu
zeigen und ich sage ihnen noch was die
ukraine könnten wir auch dadurch sichern
wenn wir aufnahmen gespräche zur eu
beginn allerdings müssen die werte in
der ukraine gesichert seien es davon
sich dasselbe passieren wie bei polen
und ungarn letzter satz die alternative
zu all diesen vorschlägen wäre eine
weitere zuspitzung mit der gefahr eines
krieges können wir deutschen vor dem
hintergrund unserer geschichte das
ernsthaft in kauf nehmen oder sogar
daran mitwirken ich denke auch an die
heutige gedenkstunde die wir erlebt
haben wir brauchen frieden durch
entspannung deeskalation
interessenausgleich und durch
verhandlungen und das wird bis zur zeit
sagt gregor gysi der außenpolitische
sprecher der linken der anders als die
russen dafür plädiert die osze
ordentlich zu stärken auch natürlich
gegen quasi die möglichkeit nur mit der
nato zu erfahren dann doch besser mit
der osze das ist zumindest die meinung
von gregor diesel und der held nächste
redner kommt jetzt von den grünen robin
wagener er ist der sprecher sie die
angelegenheit bei union und ich freue
mich auch dass seine exzellenz herr
meldet heute bei der debatte hier ist
fast auf den tag genau vor acht jahren
am 25 januar 2014 verstarb man wenig
durch die gewalt der wert gut einheiten
auf dem euro das heißt dass eine granate
ihnen schwer verwundete seine hand
zerriss und ein metall geschoss seine
lunge verletzte er überlebte die
notoperationen nicht
ich kenne die biografie dieses mannes
nicht aber er ist einer von tausenden
die seit der revolution der würde ihr
leben für demokratie für
rechtsstaatlichkeit für würde und
freiheit für die annäherung und die
mitgliedschaft in der europäischen union
der ukraine verloren haben und sie
einsetzten die mitgliedschaft in der eu
die der kreml seit jeher zu unterbinden
versucht es hat mich daher sehr gefreut
dass unsere neue außenministerin diesen
opfern am mahnmal in kiew unseren
respekt zollte und den menschen der
ukraine unsere solidarität versicherte
er bekräftigt
er bekräftigte dass unser weg nach
moskau in der frage stets über care
führen wird keine verhandlungen über die
ukraine ohne die ukraine und putin
fordert aktuell den frieden ganz europa
heraus seit dem ende des zweiten
weltkriegs hat es keine vergleichbaren
truppen konzentration samt rhetorischer
drohgebärden und kriegspropaganda
gegeben russland hat über ein drittel
seiner militärischen fähigkeiten an die
ukrainische grenze verlegt über zwei
drittel wird aktuell von russischen
streitkräfte an der grenze kontrolliert
wer von der nato einkreisung russlands
schwadroniert hat keinen blick für die
realität und es ist dabei klar und das
herz in diese richtung nicht die ukraine
sondern russland ist es hier die
eskalieren in dieser situation reicht
eine einzige fehleinschätzung die einen
flächenbrand auf dem kontinent auslösen
könnte und in dieser situation ist
frieden und diplomatie unsere stärke die
unsere gemeinschaft auszeichnen muss
wir brauchen daher wir waren daher kein
rhetorisches wettrüsten in der bild auf
twitter oder hier im saal sondern die
europa und friedenspolitische klarheit
unsere aussenministerin wie sie
gegenüber außenminister lavrov klar und
deutlich gemacht wurde eine überhitzte
debatte um waffenlieferungen schafft
keine klarheit so überlagert die
diskussion zur wirkungsvollen sanktionen
sanktionen treffen derzeit zielgenauer
als waffen es tun und sanktionen
gefährden nicht das leben der soldaten
oder der zivilbevölkerung in der ukraine
oder russland aber sie gefährden den
machtapparat im kreml der für die
bedrohung unseres friedens
verantwortlich ist den machtapparat dem
wir mit einer geschlossenen haltung und
klaren sanktionen entgegentreten und
unmissverständlich deutlich machen dass
die europäische friedensordnung nicht
verhandelbar ist und weitere
verletzungen der territorialen
integrität der ukraine hatte und
wirtschaftliche politische und
wirtschaftliche konsequenzen hätten und
bei denen wir im übrigen keine
sanktionen voreilig vom tisch nehmen
sollten gut dass sie herr merz noch mal
die kurve gekriegt haben das trifft aber
es zeigt wie gefährlich voreiliges
schwadronieren in der frage ist und ich
habe ehrlich gesagt von ihm viel kritik
gehört aber wenig konkrete vorstellung
vorschläge was kennt wirklich passieren
deutschland ist für die schwersten
menschenrechtsverletzungen auf dem boden
der ukraine verantwortlich das
verbrechen von gavin jahr in dem
innerhalb weniger stunden 33
1771 menschen durch ss und wehrmacht
ermordet wurden das einst von vielen
deutschen verbrechen auf dem boden der
ukraine russland und belarus die
strategische zurückhaltung bei
waffenlieferung sollte niemals
missverstanden werden als unterlassene
hilfeleistung nicht in kiew und schon
gar nicht in moskau in dieser frage kann
sich niemand parteipolitische
bequemlichkeiten oder simple
überschriften politik leisten es ist
eine gewisse zum anderen ich schluss
mache ich denn wir wollen und werden das
leben der menschen schützen unsere im
koalitionsvertrag vereinbarte
grundsätzliche restriktive
rüstungspolitik wird aus der
verantwortung unserer geschichte und ist
zugleich ergebnis der
gesellschaftspolitischen entwicklung
seit 1905 jetzt
verlange der solidarität mit der ukraine
und steht auch dafür dass wir fest an
der wartung zwischen frieden zu heutigen
stehenden dienten im schlussbild vielen
dank
und ich erteile das mit dem kollegen
roderich kiesewetter cdu csu fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die holocaust überlebende in
auerbach hat uns eine aufgabe mit
gegeben die aufgabe lautete eine kerze
für den frieden zu entzünden und wenn
wir heute diese kerze für den frieden
finden würden dann würde sie in einem
erheblichen gegenwind stehen lassen sie
uns eine kerze entzünden mit der
heutigen debatte für frieden und
gesicherte freiheit auch für die ukraine
nicht nur für uns liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen friedrich merz und alexander
graf lambsdorff haben sehr deutlich
gemacht dass der verursacher der
eskalation in moskau sitzt und wir
müssen sehr klar ansprechen wo ursache
und wirkung sind und es ist
geschichtsklitterung wenn
gregor gysi hier
russland das wort redet und beifall von
der afg bekommt denn erinnern wir uns an
den an die auswirkungen was die ukraine
durch zu machen hat im jahr 1994
vereinbarte man im budapester memorandum
und in vielen verhandlungen davor dass
die ukraine ihren status als
drittstärkste nuklearmacht der welt
abgibt die atomwaffen übergibt um selbst
integrität und souveränität zu erhalten
und 2014 ist dieses abkommen gebrochen
worden sämtliche nuklearverhandlungen
weltweit sind auf eis weil das beispiel
ukraine fürchten das ist die wahrheit
und her klingbeil ich hätte mir
gewünscht dass sie so klare worte
gefunden hätten wie alexander graf
lambsdorff oder friedrich merz und frau
außenministerin ich hätte mir gewünscht
dass sie diesen punkt deutlicher
herausarbeiten
es ist natürlich richtig dass wir
verhandeln aber die bundesregierung hat
in den letzten 80 tagen kein glückliches
bild abgegeben und unsere hoffnung auch
der union ist dass sie nicht in den noch
verbleibenden tagen bis sie die 100 tage
voll haben die 16 jahre verantwortlicher
aufbau verspielen es war außenminister
steinmeier der 2014 mit dem minsker
abkommen gemeinsam mit der
bundeskanzlerin und dem französischen
präsidenten erreicht hat dass wir eine
europäische lösung finden und diese
europäische lösung war damals gegen den
willen der usa die auf eine militärische
aufrüstung der ukraine setzen aber was
ist denn aus 2014 geworden wir müssen
uns doch gedanken machen ob unsere art
des umgangs seit 2014 wirklich
erfolgreich war seit wenigen wochen seit
wenigen wochen sind so viele truppen um
die ukraine stationiert wie seit dem
zweiten weltkrieg nicht mehr
wir sind am vorabend
einer kriegerischen eskalation wenn wir
nicht aufpassen wir müssen auch schauen
dass ein putin sich nicht versteigt weil
eine erwartungshaltung im eigenen volk
leistet wo er nicht mehr herunter kommt
und deshalb müssen wir und das erwarte
ich auch von ihnen herr bundeskanzler
alles tun dass der zusammenhalt der
europäischen union gewährleistet bleibt
und dass
die ukraine
ernst genommen wird wir müssen zu einem
respektvolleren umgang mit der ukraine
kommen und nicht sorglos glauben dass
wir als die der stärkste geber die
führende macht in der unter zivilen
unterstützung der ukraine dann auch auf
volles verständnis stoßen ich möchte
nicht klitschko zitieren weil es ein
sehr ernstes thema ist aber wenn die
europäischen staaten deutschland bitten
mitzuhelfen dass exporte bestimmte
systeme möglich sind dann sollten wir
hinter den kulissen ganz schnell diese
anträge gewährleisten und wir müssen von
dem verständnisvollen umgang mit
russland zu einem entschiedeneren umgang
mit russland kommen ich denke dass die
kanzlerin über viele jahre die es
versucht hat aber heute können wir nicht
das fortsetzen in dem sinne dass wir
eine art von beschwichtigung fahren wenn
russland fast 80 prozent seiner eigenen
landstreitkräfte um die ukraine
stationiert
diese truppen massierung ist einzigartig
deswegen kommt es ich möchte zum schluss
kommen damit die flamme die kerze nicht
ausgepustet wird darauf an dass wir
gemeinsam mit der eu ein starkes signal
setzen dass wir beiden den wir uns
gewünscht haben statt trump dass wir
beiden zeigen wir sind in der lage
transatlantische lastenteilung zu
bringen dass wir in der lage sind in der
europäischen sicherheit vorbildlich zu
wirken weil wir dann natürlich im
systemischen wettbewerb mit china zeigen
ob überhaupt in der lage sind in der
gleichzeitigkeit von krisen weltweit
krisenprävention auch außerhalb europas
zu leisten und drittens liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir sollten
alle sanktionen nicht ausschließen sie
müssen hart verhandelt werden nicht
alles muss öffentlich gemacht werden
aber von vornherein mit ausschließeritis
zu beginnen ist ein riesenfehler und
abschließend wir müssen unsere
bevölkerung auch darauf vorbereiten dass
sanktionen ihren preis haben sie werden
auch uns treffen weil sie ansonsten sind
sanktionen wirkungslos und wenn putin
erkennt dass wir bereit sind zu
entschiedenem handeln ermöglichen ihm
wir eben auch dass er die truppen
zurückzieht ansonsten müssen wir
geschlossen bleiben und zusammenstehen
in dem sinne danke ich ihnen für die
aufmerksamkeit und hoffe dass wir eine
kerze haben die diesem wind entgegen
steht ich danke ihnen
der nächste redner in dieser debatte der
hier sehen wir ihn schonen ist michael
roth für die spd ist vorsitzender des
auswärtigen ausschusses
sehr verehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen heute am 27
januar erinnern wir uns der opfer des
holocaust
alleine 24 millionen menschen
soldatinnen und soldaten zivilistinnen
und zivilisten
fielen dem vernichtungskrieg von nazi
deutschland auf dem gebiet der
ehemaligen sowjetunion zum opfer
unendliches leid
und wir erinnern der furchtbaren orte
des grauens und der vernichtung
das betrifft aber nicht nur
das heutige russland
das betrifft eben auch die anderen
staaten die aus der sowjetunion
hervorgegangen sind maly trotz tennis
ist ein ort der vernichtung und des
grauens in belarus
rabiya ist ein ort der vernichtung und
des grauens unweit von kirchen und
deshalb ist die verantwortung über die
wir immer wieder sprechen eine
verantwortung die wir allen staaten des
östlichen europas zuteil werden dass das
erfordert viel sensibilität aber
eben auch mitgefühl und empathie
die ukraine wird nicht irgendwie
abstrakt bedroht sie wird ganz konkret
bedroht und das seit vielen vielen
jahren
2014 die völkerrechtswidrige addition
der krim
die unterstützung die militärische
unterstützung der separatisten im osten
der ukraine das ist ein kriegsähnlicher
zustand seit vielen jahren und jetzt der
aufzug von
100.000 gefechts bereiten soldaten an
der grenze zur ukraine
das ist eine bedrohung der sicherheit
nicht nur für die ukraine nicht nur für
die staaten und gesellschaften
osteuropas es ist auch eine bedrohung
der sicherheit für uns in deutschland
und der europäischen union liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
viele in deutschland vor allem auch
meine partei sind stolz auf die
ostpolitik von willy brandt und von
vielen anderen die im prinzip die
voraussetzungen dafür geschaffen hat
dass deutschland wiedervereinigt werden
konnte aber eben auch europa
wiedervereinigt werden konnte und
deshalb muss unsere botschaft immer sein
go east ich stelle fest dass es in
unserer gesellschaft aber auch bei uns
selber viel zu wenig interesse daran
gibt was sich derzeit im östlichen
europa abspielt und wenn wir über eine
europäische ostpolitik sprechen und das
wäre meine ermunterung und meiner
ermutigung dann heißt das heute dass wir
die souveränität und die bündnisfreiheit
der staaten im osten europas anerkennen
über deren zukunft wird nicht allein in
moskau entschieden sondern in deren
hauptstädten in deren gesellschaften und
das gilt sowohl für die nato
mitgliedschaft als auch für die
mitgliedschaft in der europäischen union
wir dürfen keine türen verschließen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und wenn
wir über europäische politik sprechen
dann müssen wir immer auch die
sicherheitsinteressen unserer
mittelosteuropäischen partnerinnen und
partner mit einbeziehen wir können doch
nicht einfach die augen davor
verschließen dass sich polen und polen
die menschen in den baltischen staaten
konkret bedroht fühlen vor einer solchen
militärischen aufrüstung und wenn wir
über
europäische sicherheit sprechen dann
fordern wird so recht mehr europäische
souveränität
in der sicherheits verteidigungs und in
der außenpolitik das darf aber nicht
gegen die nato gerichtet sein sonst
verlieren wir die mittel osteuropäischen
länder die vor allem ihre
sicherheitsinteressen auch in der nato
gewahrt wissen und es muss darum gehen
dass wir die formate die wir auch wieder
ernst nehmen ze
nato-russland-rat dass wir endlich
wieder auch über angebote sprechen
können die der russland unterbreiten im
bereich der rüstungskontrolle im bereich
der abrüstung dass wir wieder
vertrauensbildend tätig sind und wenn es
etwas gibt was für mich zwingend zu
einer europäischen ost politik gehört
dann ist es die zivilgesellschaft ist
das civil society stupid wir können doch
nicht die augen davor verschließen dass
putin seit jahren die kritischen teile
der zivilgesellschaft ausgrenzt
kriminalisiert und an den rand der
gesellschaft drängt deswegen muss es uns
darum gehen dass wir dieser bewegung für
demokratie und freiheit zu mindestens
gehör verschaffen herr putin hat doch
nicht in erster linie angst vor den nato
soldaten und nato soldaten hat angst vor
der kraft von demokratie und freiheit
die von uns von der europäischen union
ausgeht und deshalb müssen wir dieser
demokratischen und freiheitlichen
bewegung auch immer wieder zum
durchbruch verhelfen dem bei diesen
menschen mut machen und ihnen sagen ja
wir nehmen auch das war was mit euch
passiert und wir brauchen last but not
least mehr austausch der begegnung ich
habe schon vor jahren vorgeschlagen dass
wir ein eigenes jugendwerk osteuropa auf
den weg bringen wo sich junge menschen
aus der europäischen union aus russland
aus anderen osteuropäischen staaten
begegnen dass wir mehr tun im bereich
von wirtschaft und wissenschaft und dass
wir hier auch dazu beitragen dass wir
endlich wieder über eine friedensordnung
sprechen können die aber nicht darauf
beruht dass
russland permanent zur destabilisierung
osteuropas beiträgt das ist kein gebot
der stunde und darüber müssen wir reden
und deswegen sind die gespräche die wir
jetzt zu führen auch unter maßgeblicher
beteiligung der bundesregierung so
unendlich wichtig
der minister hat ihr der vereinbarten
debatte über das thema frieden in europa
sicher ein territoriale integrität der
rückseite waren und der nächste redner
kommt von der af der sprecher für
außenpolitik tierte strom
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
exzellenz liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ich kann lieber herr roth ich krank
dieses gerede
davon nicht mehr hören dass russland
europa destabilisieren
das entbehrt jeder logischen grundlagen
russland
russland hat die ressourcen wir haben
das know-how es liegt im interesse der
europäischen union alle staaten in der
eu mit russland zusammenzuarbeiten
genauso wie das im interesse russlands
liegt und hier das was sie hier
vorführen mit ihrer kriegstreiberei mit
diesem mit mit der panikmache und
kriegsrhetorik ja das ist richtig
russland bewegt seine armee auf seinem
territorium richtig darüber wird hier
sehr intensiv gesprochen wird darüber
gesprochen was in der ukraine passiert
als als gegenseite ich möchte ihnen
zitieren was der ukrainische
verteidigungsminister vorgestern
vorgestern erklärt hatte
ich kann mit absoluter gewissheit sagen
dass stand heute die russischen
streitkräfte
keinen angriffs gruppierungen
aufgestellt haben die einen gewaltsamen
einmarsch in die ukraine durchführen
könnten also bitte betreiben sie hier
nicht die kriegsrhetorik hier an dieser
stelle
und hier lieber herr roth sie haben die
interessen polens angesprochen wird
nehmen die ernst ich komme gerade von
einem gespräch mit dem estnische
botschafter
ich war letzte woche im parlament in
prag wir nehmen die interessen der
mittel und osteuropäischen
länder ernst aber sie müssen sehen und
herr merz das ist nicht richtig dass die
konfrontation ausschließlich von
russland aus geht zu einem streit
gehören immer zwei mindestens zwei
manchmal sogar drei akteure das geht nie
nur mit einem
und der akteur und das ist der elefant
hier
im raum der rosa elefant das wurde noch
überhaupt nicht angesprochen sind die
usa herr merz die usa sank das doch ganz
offen dass sie russland vom stift
abschließen wollen dass sie ein embargo
verhängen wollen dass sie die
gaslieferungen von russland nach europa
stoppen wollen und uns dann als hilfe
verkauft deren überteuerte sandy
verkaufen wollen das sind doch die
interessen die hier im spiel sind
und ich war erstaunt liebe frau
aussenministerin dass wir hier so
schnell einigkeit schön denn sie haben
gesagt man soll miteinander sprechen und
die ukraine soll endlich an die
vereinbarungen von -2 erinnert werden
und zurück an den verhandlungstisch
kommen dem stimmen wir hundertprozentig
zu bitte setzen sie sich dafür ein dass
die ukraine nicht weiter eskaliert dass
sie fernsehen sender der opposition
nicht schließt das sie oppositionelle
politiker wie den unseren kollegen
parlaments
mit entschuldigt runde
widerrechtlich einsperrt sondern dass
sie zurück an den verhandlungstisch
kommt dann werden wir wieder frieden
haben danke schön
die russen setzten ungefähr 800 20.000
soldaten unter waffen von denen jetzt
etwas mehr als 100000 direkt an der
ukrainischen grenze aufmarschiert sind
das ist reiner zufall wahrscheinlich
bijan djir sarai hätte jetzt das wort
der außenpolitische sprecher der fdp
[Applaus]
fraktion
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
seit april des letzten jahres stehen
russische truppen an der grenze zur
ukraine mit der behauptung dass russland
sicherheit bedroht sei wird das
truppenaufgebot seitdem weiter verstärkt
forderungen zum abzug aus dem gebiet und
die warnung vor sanktionen blieben
bisher völlig unbeachtet ich bin
weiterhin sehr besorgt über die lage vor
ort deshalb ist es wichtig dass wir hier
heute im deutschen bundestag über den
konflikt den russland entfacht hat offen
diskutieren meine damen und herren nicht
die ukraine hat diesen konflikt entfacht
nicht die nato hat diesen konflikt
entfacht sondern russland hat diesen
konflikt entfacht meine damen und herren
diplomatie und deeskalation müssen für
uns oberstes gebot sein und bleiben
dabei dürfen wir aber die fakten in
dieser debatte nicht ignorieren es ist
nicht die sicherheit russlands die
bedroht ist es ist die ukraine die vom
russland bedroht wird es sind die
menschen in der ukraine die angst um
ihre zukunft haben immer öfter wird in
diesem zusammenhang auch der begriff der
sicherheits garantie von russischer
seite genannt ich frage mich wofür wo
russland eigentlich angst hatten wofür
russland eine sicherheitsgarantie
braucht ich glaube nicht sagt der
kollege michael roth wollen auch zu
recht gesagt ich glaube nicht dass
russland angst vor der ukraine oder vor
der nato hat russland hat angst vor
demokratie und freiheit es wäre ein
albtraum
es wäre ein albtraum für präsident putin
wenn die ukraine
europäischen demokratisch und
wirtschaftlich erfolgreich wäre deswegen
versucht russland nun schon seit vielen
jahren die ukraine übrigens ganz europa
zu destabilisieren
russland hat angst vor veränderungen und
fortschritt wenn ehemalige
sowjet-republiken der geist der freiheit
takt ist es nur eine frage der zeit ist
auch im eigenen land ähnliche bewegungen
entstehen das lässt deutlich erkennen
dass sie außenpolitische agenda des
kremls stark innenpolitisch motiviert
ist es darf nicht sein dass am ende ein
verhandlungsergebnis steht bei dem
russland ein vetorecht über die zukunft
anderer staaten hat und herr kollege die
sie herr kollege die sie weil sie das
auch vorhin bei ihrer rede erwähnt haben
es gibt ein grund warum die menschen in
diesen ländern zur nato wollen in die
nato wollen der grund ist weil sie angst
vor russland haben um weil sie sich
hoffnungen machen eine zukunft in
sicherheit zu haben und das sollte bei
dieser debatte ebenfalls erwähnt werden
aus unserer sicht ist es von großer
bedeutung dass der kreml den preis
weitere eskalation kennt zu einer
realistischen außenpolitik gehört dass
alle optionen auf dem tisch bleiben wenn
wir wollen dass diplomatie eine chance
hat und wenn wir wollen dass uns
russland ernst nimmt dann müssen alle
optionen auf dem tisch bleiben meine
damen und herren
eine eine russische eine russische
invasion wäre nicht irgendein fehler
grenzkonflikt sondern ein fundamentaler
schlag gegen unsere europäische
sicherheits ordnung und
sicherheitsarchitektur
wir sind freunde des russischen volkes
und haben großen respekt vor den
menschen in russland wir leben aber die
aktuelle politik der russischen führung
entschieden ab der gegenwärtige
russische weg ist ein irrweg der
unweigerlich in die isolation führt
präsident putin muss klar sein dass sein
verhalten gravierende folgen haben wird
die nicht im russischen interesse liegen
können ich bedauere sehr ich bedaure es
sehr meine damen und herren das derzeit
eine debatte über die
sicherheitsarchitektur in europa
stattfindet und diese debatte im
wesentlichen zwischen usa und russland
geführt wird europa sitzt nicht dabei
und es gibt einen grund warum europa
nicht dabei ist wir haben es uns ist es
in den letzten jahren in europa meine
damen und herren nicht gelungen mit
einer gemeinsamen europäischen außen und
sicherheitspolitik zu sprechen wir als
europäer haben uns in den letzten jahren
klein gemacht und jetzt bezahlen wir
auch den preis leider dafür wir sind bei
dieser wichtigen debatte nicht dabei ich
wünsche mir ich wünsche mir dass sich
das für die zukunft ändert die
prinzipien frau präsidentin ein letzter
gedanke die prinzipien des völkerrechts
des völkerrechts der menschenrechte und
der europäischen friedensordnung sind
nicht verhandelbar vielen dank meine
damen und herren
bijan djir sarai hier mit der richtigen
feststellung dass europa eigentlich
nicht gemeinsam spricht und nicht am
tisch sitzt herr labor auf der
außenminister hat ja auch gesagt die
europäer spielen für ihn keine rolle er
sieht die verhandlungen mit den
amerikanern als hauptverhandlung an und
dann vielleicht noch das normandie
format johannes schraps jetzt für die
spd ja der frau präsidentin sehr geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen die frage die
uns hier alle beschäftigt die auch
medial derzeit rauf und runter gefragt
wird auch mir in den letzten tagen
mehrfach sie ist an sicher etwas skurril
die frage ob russland nun einen krieg
gegen die ukraine anfängt die frage die
friedrich merz zielgerade gestellt hat
ob es einen krieg in europa gibt sie ist
skurril denn diesen krieg gegen die
ukraine und da wird mir botschafter
melnik sicher auch zustimmen diesen
krieg den gibt es bereits seit 2014 und
er dauert leider bis heute an sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
in diesem sinne ist auch der erste teil
des titels unserer heutigen debatte
frieden in europa sichern fast etwas
irreführend denn wir haben diesen krieg
seit 2014 bereits aber in der tat hat
sich die situation mit dem russischen
truppenaufmarsch in den vergangenen
wochen besorgniserregend zugespitzt und
selbstverständlich muss aktuell derzeit
alles daran gesetzt werden um mit
diplomatischen mitteln eine weitere
eskalation dieses krieges zu verhindern
so wie es unsere bundesregierung
richtigerweise tut
offensichtlich fällt es der russischen
staatsführung außerordentlich schwer das
selbstbestimmungsrecht der völker als
grundlage des völkerrechts anzuerkennen
und weil es putin für sein
innenpolitisches narrativ braucht möchte
er ebenso wenig sehen dass die
nato-mitgliedschaft einzelner
nachbarstaaten keine gefahr oder
bedrohung für russland darstellt umso
wichtiger ist es gegenüber putin sehr
deutlich zu artikulieren dass es erneut
dass die erneut im raum stehende
verletzung der territorialen integrität
der ukraine keinesfalls toleriert wird
die unverletzlichkeit von grenzen
verehrte kolleginnen und kollegen muss
wieder von allen akzeptiert werden
insofern stimmt zumindest der zweite
teil des titels unserer tipp debatte und
ich bin froh dass dieses klare signal
auch aus dieser heutigen debatte ganz
eindeutig hervorgeht in den letzten
tagen wurde immer wieder kritik daran
laut dass deutschland keine waffen an
die ukraine liefert für mich persönlich
bleibt die frage offen ob
waffenlieferungen in die ukraine
tatsächlich mehr sicherheit gegenüber
einer bedrohung durch russland bringen
oder ob sie nicht im gegenteil einen
konflikt anheizen können der vielleicht
besser auf anderen wegen entschärft
werden sollte unsere position ist
jedenfalls deutlich so lange eine
friedliche lösung möglich ist werden wir
sie anstreben und dafür muss auf
diplomatischem wege jede möglichkeit
genutzt werden verehrte bewegen
und das ist hat dann auch nichts mit
russland freundlichkeit oder mit
freundlichkeit zu irgendeinem land zu
tun sondern mit einem umsichtigen
bedachten vorgehen das auf eine
friedliche konfliktlösung ausgerichtet
ist und zugleich sagen wir der
russischen führung da ganz klar und
deutlich dass ein einmarsch in die
ukraine einen sehr hohen preis haben
würde und zu recht tun wir das in der
heutigen debatte ja parteiübergreifend
auch nochmal mit besonderem nachdruck
verehrte kolleginnen und kollegen als
europapolitiker möchte ich hier noch
einen aspekt betonen der mir in einer
zumindest öffentlich medial teils sehr
polarisierten debatten viel zu kurz
kommen nämlich die gemeinsame
europäische außenpolitik
der eu außenbeauftragte joseph corre er
hatte die hat die ukraine zu recht als
einen teil europas bezeichnen und auch
betont dass es keine sicherheit in
europa ohne die sicherheit der ukraine
gibt beides stimmt nur sitzt europa das
hat der kollege die österreich gerade
richtiger weise angesprochen bei den
gesprächen zwischen putin den usa der
nato selten wirklich mit am tisch und
wir müssen als europäer aufpassen dass
wir in einer großmacht
auseinandersetzung auf europäischer
stellvertreter bühne nicht zum
vollkommen unbeteiligten zuschauer
werden und leider wird in der
öffentlichen debatte aber weniger über
die möglichkeiten eines gemeinsamen
europäischen vorgehens gesprochen wie es
außenministerin berbalk
dankenswerterweise vorhin sehr deutlich
getan
vielmehr werden vermeintliche
unterstützungsleistungen einzelner
länder einander gegenübergestellt und
gegeneinander aufgewogen die baltischen
staaten liefern luftabwehrraketen die
ukraine versucht gegenüber deutschland
aus der fehlleistung einer einzelnen
person die nebenbei bemerkt sehr klare
und schnelle konsequenzen nach sich
gezogen hat sehr grundsätzliche
forderungen abzuleiten polen verkauft
bereits seit jahren gepanzerte fahrzeuge
an die ukraine die briten lieferten
panzerabwehrwaffen und deutschland und
frankreich versuchen derweil normandie
format auf diplomatischem wege zu einer
entspannung des konflikts beizutragen es
ist gut dass seit gestern in paris nach
langer zeit endlich wieder gespräche in
diesem format stattfanden ich denke wir
alle wünschen uns dass sie erfolgreich
zu einer deeskalation beitragen können
die beispiele zeigen aber deutlich den
fehlenden konsens für eine gemeinsame
außenpolitik und diese uneinigkeit wie
bringt europa in die zuschauerrolle
dabei geht es nicht nur um die aktuelle
situation sondern es geht um die
grundsätzliche frage ob europa als
starker politischer akteur gemeinsam
handeln und auftreten kann kurzfristig
wünsche ich mir deshalb eine
diplomatische konfliktlösung über die
gestern wieder begonnenen gespräche in
normandie format mittel und langfristig
wünsche ich mir dass wir europäer
endlich als gemeinsamer außenpolitischer
akteur auftreten um uns in
konfliktsituationen nicht als kleine
einzelstaaten sondern gemeinsam mit
kraft und nachdruck für friedliche
lösungen einsetzen können herzlichen
dank
herr kollege
gemeinsame außenpolitik früher hat die
stadt gefunden in europa dass minsk
abkommen kam ja nur zustande weil
weil die franzosen und die deutschen
gemeinsam gearbeitet haben und ob das
immer noch so sein kann das ist die
frage ob herr putin das auch so sieht
die nächste frühling haben jetzt der
verteidigungspolitische sprecher der cdu
csu wenn ich die sehr geehrte
kolleginnen kollegen wenn ich die ersten
wochen der regierungsarbeit der neuen
links gelben koalition betrachte muss
ich immer wieder an einen satz aus einer
legendären reportage von den olympischen
winterspielen 1980 in lake placid denken
der damalige zdf reporter bruno moravetz
rief damals mit blick auf den verlauf
der langlauf disziplin wo ist behle
viele haben wir noch nicht gesehen wir
wissen nichts wir sehen ihn nicht behle
ist weg wie würde moravetz wo die
aktuelle arbeit der bundesregierung und
ihre performance zu den aktuellen top
themen wie impfpflicht oder ukraine sind
kommentieren er würde vermutlich rufen
wo ist stolz stolz haben wir noch nicht
gesehen wir wissen nichts wir sehen und
hören ihn nicht stolz ist will denn das
ist denn das ist denn das ist der
eindruck
denn das ist der eindruck den nicht nur
wir sondern zunehmend auch ein großteil
der bevölkerung im moment von ihnen und
ihrer arbeit haben herr bundeskanzler
gravierend kommt hinzu dass das auch der
eindruck der bündnispartner in europa
und in der nato sie waren 16 jahre
andere
regierungsarbeit gewohnt nämlich das
konsequente engagement einer
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel sie hat
die europäische familie zusammengehalten
und dem rad nach moskau nie abreißen
lassen sie hat mit putin auf augenhöhe
in minsk verhandelt und in ihrer
amtszeit wussten unsere partner auch
deutschland kann man sich verlassen
wo ist albrecht ich finde die
bundesverteidigungsministerium die als
inhaberin der befehls und kommandogewalt
der bundeswehr eine der größten
streitkräfte in europa und in der nato
in sie sollte in dieser frage doch auch
eine besonders aktive rolle spielen sie
ist heute noch nicht mal hier bei dieser
rede auf der regierungsbank dass sich
aber bis zum gestrigen tag noch nicht
einmal ein gespräch mit dem ukrainischen
amtskollegen geführt hat spricht bände
wir als cdu csu wollen dass die ukraine
krise diplomatisch gelöst wird das
bedeutet verhandeln auf höchstem niveau
dabei ist es entscheidend mögliche
maßnahmen und folgen einer russischen
eskalation nicht unnötig vom tisch zu
nehmen das gilt auch für die frage von
waffenlieferungen zur stärkung der
selbstverteidigung der ukraine eine
schwierige frage gerade für deutschland
wir stehen dem traditionell sehr
skeptisch gegenüber dass dies aber auch
richtig und wichtig sein kann hat sich
bei der unterstützung für die kurden zur
bekämpfung der ces gezeigt deshalb
sollten wir diese option eben nicht vom
tisch nehmen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wenn wir über die ukraine krise
sprechen und welt politik machen dann
entsteht manchmal der eindruck dass wir
die menschen vergessen die diese krise
direkt betrifft und das sind die
menschen in der ukraine
das sind zum beispiel mütter und väter
die angst um ihre kinder haben die im
zweifel bereit sind ihr land und die
freiheit der ukraine zu verteidigen
diese menschen erhoffen sich von uns
unterstützung in dieser krise deshalb
ist es so wichtig ein signal zu setzen
europa und der westen sind an der seite
der ukraine besonders hoch ist dabei
gerade auch der erwartungsdruck auf
deutschland dass die bundesregierung
glaubt mit einer lieferung von 5.000
helmen an die ukraine dieses signal der
unterstützung zu senden und dem
erwartungsdruck an uns herr zu werden
ist ein großer irrtum das war
das war kein befreiungsschlag die
bundesregierung sondern ein echter
beschämender rohrkrepierer
meine damen und herren wir fragen uns in
diesen tagen und auch bei dieser debatte
immer wieder warum kommt es zu dieser
krise und was ist der grund für den
konflikt den die ukraine und am besten
auf der einen seite und die russische
föderation auf der anderen seite
miteinander haben ich glaube ein grund
ist dass wir die
andere ansichten darüber haben was im
interesse eines landes auch mit blick
auf die nachbarschaftspolitik ist wir
haben durch die europäische integration
gelernt geht es unseren nachbarn gut
profitieren wir selbst massiv davon
moskau sieht das genau anders dort
befürchtet man den erfolg des nachbarns
weil er gefahr für die eigene innere
stabilität ist nichts wird dort so
gefürchtet wie die freiheit die
meinungsfreiheit die wahlfreiheit die
religionsfreiheit die pressefreiheit und
die versammlungsfreiheit und diese
freiheit beansprucht die ukraine zu
recht für sich und wir können gar nicht
anders als sie dabei auch zu
unterstützen klar ist aber auch dass
russland unser nachbar ist und bleibt
und wir natürlich ein übergroßes
interesse an einer guten und
gedeihlichen zusammenarbeit haben
deshalb bitte ich uns alle lassen sie
uns alle alles daran setzen diesen
konflikt im interesse aller zu
entschärfen die cdu csu fraktion in
ihrer rolle wird sich dabei in diesem
sinne zu 1000 prozent engagieren
herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
mittlerweile hat wolfgang kubicki das
pult übernommen als amtierende
sitzungspräsident und der letzte redner
hier in der debatte wird jetzt für ohhh
weingarten von der spd sein er ist
mitglied im verteidigungsausschuss der
präsident liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
meine damen und herren die aktuelle lage
in um die ukraine ist brandgefährlich
sie bedroht den frieden in ganz europa
und die ukraine in ihrer territorialen
integrität
es ist doch unstrittig und hier mehrfach
schon deutlich geworden die regierung im
kreml ist der aggressor nicht die
ukraine russland versucht seine
interessen mit militärischen
drohgebärden durchzusetzen das werden
wir nicht akzeptieren
deswegen unser klarer appell präsident
putin ziehen sie ihre truppen von der
ukrainischen grenze zurück und
unterlassen sie alle maßnahmen zur
destabilisierung der ukraine
mich irritieren jedoch auch manche
reaktionen in unserer deutschen
diskussion ich höre dort teilweise eine
lust an der konflikt verschärfung heraus
die der brisanz der lage nicht
angemessen ist weder die leier von einer
stets aggressiven nato politik noch die
kritiklose verehrung der russischen
gewaltpolitik die wir hier aus den
linken und rechten fraktionen des
deutschen bundestages hören werden dem
problem gerecht wir brauchen keine
ideologie soll ein pragmatisches handeln
und es ist eine völlig falsche
sichtweise zu hoffen dass die lieferung
von tod briefen bringenden waffen in
dieser krisensituation
etwas zur entspannung der krise
beitragen würde die sozialdemokratischen
bundestagsfraktion stütz deshalb ohne
einschränkungen die linie der
bundesregierung und des bundeskanzlers
keine legalen waffen in das krisengebiet
zu liefern
den kolleginnen kollegen der union die
zweite niederlage sich sind sich den
namen der bundesverteidigungsministerium
zu merken die heißt nämlich lamprecht
herr kollege haben aber gleichzeitig
weitere waffenlieferungen fordern machen
sie sich doch nichts vor deutsche
waffenlieferungen die ukraine würden
wenig helfen aber gleichzeitig von der
kreml propaganda maschine als massive
provokation verstanden werden egal wie
gut unsere vorsitzende oder begründungen
dabei wären und weitere provokationen
brauchen wir nicht deutschlands rolle
muss eine andere sein druck auf russland
auszuüben ohne die militärische
situation anzuheizen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir
stehen auch zu unseren verbündeten in
der nato und so truppen in litauen
stehen dort nicht nur symbolisch unser
herzlicher dank gilt unseren soldatinnen
und soldaten und ihrem einsatz jeglicher
angriff auf diese verbündeten und auch
auf unsere soldatinnen und soldaten wäre
auf einen angriff auf die nato insgesamt
wir nehmen auch die bedrohungen die
unsere polnischen und belgischen partner
inzwischen auch die finnischen und
schwedischen freunde spüren sehr ernst
über ihre sicherheitsinteressen werden
wir nicht hinweggehen bündnisfreiheit
und völkerrecht sind nicht verhandelbar
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ist es
sehr viel die rede von respekt das ist
auch richtig die völker russlands und
der ukraine verdienen respekt mehr noch
angesichts dessen was sie was ihnen aus
unserem land heraus angetan wurde
verdienen sie unsere b mut demut vor
ihrer geschichte und ihren opfern aber
das gilt auch für beide seiten dieses
konflikts auch politiker verdienen
respekt jedenfalls manche seit präsident
putin an dieser stelle und vor mehr als
20 jahren im september 2001 gesprochen
hat hat er viel getan um den ihm
gebührenden respekt zu schmälern die
unterdrückung der demokratischen
opposition und der zivilgesellschaft
einschränkung der pressefreiheit das
aggressive verhalten gegenüber den
nachbarn unser wille zum gespräch bleibt
aber weit gehen und vor weiterhin
unverändert wir sozialdemokraten
unterstützen das normandie font format
mit russland und der ukraine frankreich
und deutschland
wir begrüßen ausdrücklich dass präsident
marco und bundeskanzler stolz hier
engagiert voran gehen dialog statt
eskalation der campbell muss
deeskalieren aber alle beteiligten
können zur stabilisierung der äußerst
gefährlichen lage beitragen lassen sie
uns gemeinsam auf diesem weg weitergehen
herzlichen dank
vielen dank
weingarten